you've kind of been fed this idea that
you just need high intensity all the
time unfortunately
you need more than that because you can
only do high intensity for so long
before you break and you need something
in between and so those
lower and more moderate intensity
sessions allow you to do more volume to
get more stimulus
without breaking yourself so you need
that balance so the average person that
they just spend
four or five days a week up to six for
higher levels and they're consistently
doing some form of aerobic training you
know the majority time they're doing
lower more moderate intensity work 30 40
minutes
sometimes more sometimes less and then
they're spending maybe two days a week
doing those higher intensity intervals
and they are getting their heart rates
up towards maximum
and they consistently do that you will
see your hiv consistently climb
guarantee you
i wanted to dig into hiv today hiv is
like
the hot new girl in school at the moment
yeah in terms of the metrics
it's funny because i've been using it
since like the early 2000s and i used to
go into a
presentation i'd say who here's using
hrv or who's got hiv and people look at
me like i was
asking about an std or something because
they just had no clue what the hell the
thing was back then right
uh but but yeah now it's everywhere
apple watches got it and people are
talking about it it's
it's you know it's such a big change
from where it was like i said 15 20
years ago when i was first getting into
it so
it's it's exciting to see because it's a
valuable metric it's it's one of the few
pieces of fitness tech that truly can
change people's outcomes and have them
you know get better results you're ahead
of the curve man trendsetter
yeah i mean it was i was just uh i wish
i claimed it was
entirely intentional but i just kind of
stumbled upon to it and once i did then
i immediately saw the value and
and jumped into it but i would never
predicted you know way back then it
would
get as popular as it is now so it's uh
you know it's definitely been a journey
to get there for sure
how did you get started with it yeah so
kind of a crazy story there's a guy
named randy huntington
uh who a lot of people probably are not
familiar with but randy is a
fantastic track coach he worked with
mike powell when mike powell broke carl
lewis is like 20-year
long long jump world record and he's a
local guy and i'd
just kind of come to meet him as a young
coach and asked him some
you know some tips and things he would
advise and you know just general advice
from an old guy to a young guy
and he said uh you should look at this
thing called the omega wave and i was
like what the hell's the omega wave and
he just kind of gave me a number
and said call call this guy and it's
okay i'm okay so
i call this this number it's just thick
accent sounds like russian or eastern
european
and i'm like barely understand the guy
but he's telling me to meet him at an
airport the next day so i'm like
i'm like am i going to get kidnapped
like when am i going to sell the guy
vodka like what's going on here
so i go down the airport and there's a
guy in this long trench coat and
literally i'm like
is this kgb or just like a practical
joker what the hell's going on here
and he tells me basically in the hotel
airport to
lay down on the couch and take my shirt
off and i'm
i'm seriously like this makes no sense
but i trust randy and if i'm
you know like okay if a russian man in a
trench coat says to take my top off in
an airport i'll do it
exactly so anyway so i laid down the
couch i take
my shirt off and he connects a bunch of
electrodes to me and and tells me to be
quiet for a couple minutes and i
look over and he's plugging all these
electrodes into this big computer and
all this shit's happening on the screen
in the background i'm completely lost at
this point i mean bear in mind this is
like 2 000
maybe 2001-ish so there's no fitness
tech there's no
mobile apps you know there's no fitbit
like none of this stuff exists
so there was nothing and so all of a
sudden two and a half three minutes go
by and he's
telling me like oh your cardiovascular
condition is [ __ ] and your central
nervous system is good and
your recovery is very bad right he
starts just kind of like telling me all
these things about my training and
and kind of the nature of i was an
anaerobic athlete at that point in time
and just powerlifted mostly
and he's able to tell me all this stuff
despite not knowing anything about me
and so i was like how in the hell is
this
working you know is this some russian
voodoo or like what is this and so
essentially kind of tells me that the
the russians pioneered this technology
called heart rate
variability then they'd use it in the
original space program with the
astronauts
or cosmonauts back then so the
interesting thing is he said that
basically
it had been used in space medicine for
for decades
and then the 1980s the russians had
tried to figure out how to make this
uh applicable to athletes and so they
started this giant program where they
were developing it for
their olympic athletes and for their
national athletes
and kind of as they were developing this
program the soviet union crumbled the
whole thing
fell apart basically the program was
never completed
and so you know fast forward maybe 10
years and a bunch of the original
scientists had still kind of been in the
sporting world and stumbled onto each
other to track me in eugene oregon of
all places
and they'd all just kind of started
talking about this project they should
have finished and never got to
see through and they formed the
microwave company and started the
project back
up and finished kind of the first
commercial grade heart rate variability
tech
and it was you know it was very
expensive so when i you know i'm sitting
in my early twenties i'm like well how
much is this thing i've got to have this
damn thing and he's like
35 000 and i was like 35 000
dollars like jesus i didn't have 350 at
the time i was i was you know buried out
of college and i was totally broke
uh but i i just said you know is there
any way i can work some payment plans or
help you sell this thing like what could
i do like you know i
was desperate to have it because i just
saw the potential of it and so
um you know i just kind of wheeled and
dealt unfortunately russians are
our will to negotiate a bit and so i was
you know i
i got a i got a used system that had you
know just kind of an old laptop and
older one of their models that
they were just kind of going to recycle
anyway um and convinced that i could
introduce it to other coaches and the
industry that i knew and help them get
it started north america because that
point they had
almost nobody in north america using it
i mean maybe randy and a couple other
coaches
but they had primarily been focused on
europe and track and field and you know
high level
sports and so uh you know make a long
story short i was able to
to help them out with that and get good
more coaches aware of it and then i
started using it but the funny thing was
because i had kind of negotiated this
discounted rate
there wasn't much training involved it
was like uh 10 minutes so here's this
thing here
here's how you connect it here's kind of
how it works versus a two-day training
that i found everyone else got
so a lot of it was just trial and error
and figuring out what the hell this
thing was doing
and then i kind of realized okay i kind
of understand what you're doing now but
i don't really know how to explain to
people
and so i i kind of became the russian
guy like people come to my gym back lay
down and take your shirt off right like
what come on meet me and meet me in the
airport bring a kalashnikov
yeah yeah exactly exactly so it was it
was awkward days and then
then i kind of had i need to put six
electrodes on and like three were in the
chest and then
you know i have female athletes and
clients come in i'm like um i'm gonna
put my hand
here but i promise this is this is gonna
be valuable for
for you and this is real this isn't me
trying to do something odd so it was
you know like i said back then there was
there was no fitness tech and so i had
this laptop and this little
black box and all these electrodes and
it was just you know it was the wild
west of
of early days of fitness tech but uh you
know i said now it's evolved the point
where you've got this thing in a million
different devices and
people know what it is or at least they
have some idea of what it is but it's
it's certainly come a long way from from
those days yeah
probably for the better as well if
you've got to strap a bunch of
electrodes onto someone it wouldn't be
quite as popular i don't think
take us through it then hiv how do you
define it
so you know in a nutshell all we're
really doing is measuring the pattern of
your heart rhythm
so people typically think the heart
beats like a metronome
which makes sense but that's actually
not how it beats it's got a natural
rhythm to it
and that natural rhythm changes
depending on how your body is
regulating itself and how your body is
distributing energy so
when you're at rest your body has a
certain heart rhythm that's associated
with what we call the parasympathetic
nervous system that's the rest digest
system and the stronger that pattern
towards
that side of it the more your body is
driving energy towards recovery
when you are under a period of stress or
your body is producing more energy or
that sympathetic system is
is more at play then we see a different
pattern in heart rhythm because again
these two systems
influence how the heart beats and so
we're just basically looking at that
pattern to figure out okay is the body
in this fight-or-flight
state or is the body in this recovery
state and where is it in that spectrum
because it's a spectrum it's not really
like a light switch
it's it's more about a spectrum it's
only light switch on the far far ends of
that spectrum so
what we're really trying to do is just
see where is the body distributing the
energy that's producing is it focusing
its energy more on the rest and
digesting recovery and rebuilding type
of things or is it currently under a
period of stress or is it still
in that fight or flight state after
workout or mental stress or
or life stress or whatever the case may
be so we're really just trying to
understand how is the body
regulating itself internally and we're
doing that just by looking at how that
heart is beating
because again that heart rate that heart
rhythm and that pattern is governed by
the autonomic
nervous system which is again what
manages how energy is distributed
throughout the body so
it's a you know it's a hugely valuable
tool because of that because if you
could understand
where the body is in terms of its
recovery versus its
stress and how well it's recovering from
everything you're throwing at it
then you can have a whole lot of better
information about what's the right
choice
to do now you know do i need more
recovery or is my body already handling
everything well do i focus
uh you know more on this and more on
that it gives us a lot of
guidelines as far as what you know we
should be doing and what we shouldn't be
doing
and then likewise the the number itself
heart rate variability is
is mostly a measure of that that
parasympathetic
recovery-driven energy system or sorry
autonomic part of the nervous system
so higher in general is protective
because it's anti-inflammatory because
it's connected to aerobics business
and in lots of reasons it's basically a
really good marker of overall longevity
and overall ability to recover from the
stress of life so it's
if we look at that single number over
time we said never going up
over time then that's telling us our
body is getting more resilient it's
getting more
durable it's getting more robust and
able to handle a higher level stress if
that number is
lower then it's a bad thing it basically
tells us we're going
the opposite direction so if we look at
it on a daily basis
we see these changes up and down as we
train and as we deal with life stress
and that just gives us this kind of
daily road map to figure out what's
what's the appropriate level of stress
but if you look at the long term we can
see is our body getting
more adept is our body getting more
resilient or are we going
the other direction so it can kind of
give us two big pieces of data that are
really important for fitness and health
and performance so we look at it either
in the daily level or if we zoom out
and we look at kind of the long-term
trends behind it
hivs associated with longevity higher
hiv is associated with people who live
longer
absolutely yeah so it's associated with
vo2 max which is a huge predictor
and marker of cardiovascular fitness
which is so look you got to take a step
back here and realize
that in the u.s it's not a whole lot
different in the uk
roughly one out of every three people
will die from cardiovascular related
diseases
that's ridiculous right i mean one out
of three so 30 plus percent
are going to die from a cardiovascular
related disease or event
so if a third of the population is dying
that and we're looking at measures that
protect against that then that's
naturally going to protect you from
cardiovascular disease which is going to
kill a third of the population so
even just from that standpoint it
correlates to longevity well because
you're
much less likely to die from
cardiovascular disease if you have a
strong cardiovascular system
which hiv correlates extremely well to
on the other side it protects against
just kind of this all-cause mortality
because as i mentioned
the parasympathetic nervous system is
anti-inherently anti-inflammatory so
if you look at the autonomic nervous
system you have those two branches i
mentioned the sympathetic
the you know the fight-or-flight system
and that system is inherently
pro-inflammatory
so if you're producing lots of energy
you're under lots of stress
your immune system is naturally kind of
on high alert and you're able to produce
a lot more inflammation
because of that it's it's a it's a
protective thing if you if you actually
are in a
survival situation you want that nervous
system or you want you want that
immune response because there's a higher
likelihood that you're gonna be exposed
to
infection or tissue damage all these
sorts of things
so that sympathetic nervous system that
stress system is designed to be a bit
and you know bit pro-inflammatory it
releases little markers called cytokines
but on the other side that
parasympathetic nervous system its job
is to turn off
that's that inflammation its job is to
repair those tissues so it's
anti-inflammatory so
again a lot of disease in the modern era
is
disease of chronic inflammation it's how
we see all kinds of
uh different things develop to kill us
so if you can develop that
parasympathetic nervous system
and you can develop a stronger level of
it then you can be more
anti-inflammatory you can protect
against
the normal inflammatory damage that we
you know expose ourselves to across our
lifetime so if you can protect
you know against that inflammation with
a better developed nervous system
then your chances of living longer go up
so heart rate variability is
the single best measure we have of that
parasympathetic nervous system and
thereby
the single best measure we have of how
anti-inflammatory
we can be and how we can mitigate
against just the stress of life
why is it that hiv is associated with
greater recovery like what is it
that that reduction in the difference
between the heartbeats is achieving well
so it's not really the reduction of
difference between heartbeats it's it's
greater variability in that heart rate
pattern and that just in
that basically comes from the
parasympathetic nervous system so
if you're at rest it's mostly the
parasympathetic nervous system
activating and deactivating with your
respiratory function
that's causing the heart rhythm to
change so the greater parasympathetic
nervous system activity
the greater variation in your heart rate
we see over the measurement period
so if we see this large variation in one
beat to the next on average
that's that is what hrv is heart rate
variability
then again we know that it's the
parasympathetic nervous system is
it's stronger it's more active if we see
more of a flat pattern we see less
variability we know that that the
parasympathetic nervous system is less
active and the sympathetic
version or system is a bit more active
so
again that's that's just a telltale sign
of the body is
able to distribute energy into recovery
the more active that parasympathetic
nervous system
is because that's the parasympathetic
sources job is literally to drive energy
into recovery it's to increase
protein synthesis and people look at
this way it's really simple
the parasympathetic nervous system is
anabolic it helps rebuild tissues
and the sympathetic system is catabolic
it helps break down tissues for energy
and to deal with stress
so again it's that balance if we're
chronically catabolic and we're
chemically you know we're always
breaking tissue down and we're
chronically
in this inflamed state we're going to
have diseases we're going to have
problems but if we're able to rebuild
through that parasympathetic nervous
system and we have to be more anabolic
and tip that scale back the other
direction towards growth and repair
then we're much more likely to be
healthy and much less likely to have
you know chronic inflammatory diseases
and and all those things that come with
that
so high hiv is good is that relative or
absolute
if i have a hiv of 50 and you have one
of 100
are you twice as parasympathetic as i
am is it all relative within my
physiology
yeah so there's a couple things the
first thing is there's a lot of
different ways to calculate it there's
not
just one calculation so the difference
is if we look at heart rate it's very
simple it's the number of beats
your at your heart's being per minute
but if we look at heart rate variability
there's multiple types of calculations
from what's called rmssd
to sdnn to pn5 there's there's multiple
ways to calculate that
number yeah so it's just more difficult
to compare
me to you or the reality it's much more
difficult to compare
one system's hrb number versus another
systems hiv number because
right now there's so many systems out
there and they all have different
calculations
and then they all put them on different
scales or different ways to quantify
them so
the number on one system really is
meaningless to say oh well i have a 50
on this system
but you're 75 on that system that that
number is not as universally
comparable as heart rate itself so you
really can't say okay well you're 50 or
80.
unless you're looking at the exact same
heart rate variability system or the
exact same heart rate variability
calculation
those numbers to compare against are
meaningless but
if your two people were using the same
system the same exact way of calculating
hrv in the same exact scale
then yeah higher number would be
healthier
for anybody it doesn't really matter but
what we see is that
age groups have norms so as you age you
lose some of that recovery ability you
start to decline over time so that's
what we see is if you look at someone's
average
like if you take a population and you
take somebody in their 70s people in
their 70s are going to have lower hiv
and average than somebody in their 20s
who's going to have higher rates of 30s
40s it's going to decline with age
so there are certainly age-driven norms
that you want to be
at the top of and you want to be as as
high as possible given
your age so it's more about where is my
hiv in relation to somebody in my
age range given the tech the exact
hiv system i'm using to compare myself
against
so and it's also it's like a two to one
like oh i'm a hundred so i'm twice as
you know it's not quite that linear um
but it
in general you want again you want to
compare yourself against other people in
your age group
on whatever system you're using because
it's it's it's really the only way to
get a
a fair comparison to see where you stack
up relative to other people now
the good thing is if you the other
metric you can use that's
much more universal is resting heart
rate
so resting heart rate and hiv will have
an inverse correlation
meaning people with higher heart rate
variability are going to have a lower
resting heart rate because part of what
drives that rescue heart rate down is
that parasympathetic nervous system
and the other part of it is just the
structural and functional changes that
come along with aerobic fitness
which is also what drives hiv up so if
you want to compare yourself you can
pretty much look at what is my resting
heart rate
relative to somebody else and chances
are pretty good that if i have a
lower resting heart rate i'm probably
also going to have a higher hrv on
average than somebody else so again we
can use
just rest and heart rate which is a more
comparable number that everyone can look
at and compare themselves against
uh to have a pretty good idea of what
our hiv is likely going to be it's
pretty rare you're going to see somebody
with
a very low resting heart rate and and
also not have a pretty good
uh hrv you generally would see those
again correlate in the inverse way so
if i'm going to compare two people i
can't really do it with hiv unless
they're using the same system
but i can compare rest and heart rate
and that's where we can have a fair
a fair game to see what you know what
those numbers look like
are those the two most important metrics
that you look at
they they are yeah i mean so if you dig
in the research i mean
most of the research on longevity and
all that sort of stuff is is done
basically on
vo2 max which is kind of the gold
standard of lab testing of hard
cardiovascular fitness
but again those things are difficult to
measure i'm not going to go to lab and
get my vo2 max tested it sucks it's a
shitty test people don't want to do it
so we
right we can we can look at rest and
heart rate and we can look at hrb as a
proxy
because those are going to correlate
such a high level they're much much
easier to measure
now the third one i would say that also
correlates extremely well because it's
all on the same vein
is heart rate recovery so there's a
number of studies and things you can
look at where
the faster your heart rate will drop
after exertion the better
your overall parasympathetic nervous
system is the higher your hrv is
the better aerobic shape you're in
because ultimately the faster we can
drop the rest and heart rate it means
that we're in better aerobic
condition and we're going to see all
those other characteristics that come
along with that so i use that one all
the time for training you know
we'll look at you know a period of
exertion we'll look at how some high
intensity work
and you give them you know either 30 60
seconds and you see how fast their heart
rate comes down the faster heartbeat
comes down
the more likely they are to have again
higher hiv and lower rest and heart rate
and all that sort of stuff but
those are really kind of the the you're
going to look at you're not going to
look at hrv
in workout this is done at rest and
you're not going to look at rest and
heart rate in the workout because it's
again done at rest
so from a from a tracking standpoint
we'll use
hrv and resin heart rate from an in
workout standpoint we'll typically look
at
heart rate recovery that's cool what's
the highest hiv that you've ever seen
uh you know again it depends on the
system but uh the the one that
people in the uk might be familiar with
over there is athlete which is a really
good one actually that
first one of the first companies i
worked with was was simon i think over
there
and simon and and isolate in my first
system bio force hiv we worked
basically with the same general
algorithm same general scale
so on that one you know if you get up
around 100 it'd be a very high
hiv you'd see a few people here and
there would be like 105 110
which was extremely high in kind of the
far end of the endurance spectrum
but again that's there's other systems
out there that can show you 200 so it's
it's all relative but uh you usually
will definitely see the the endurance
athletes and the people that
are doing hours and hours of volume tend
to fall up in that uh that hundred range
if you're looking at
uh some of the more popular ones i said
bioforce my original one ifleet and a
few of the other ones out there
but uh again it really depends on the
system you're using so it's hard to say
yeah given that 110 is like the absolute
top end of what you saw there
i'm in a woop team with ryan fisher
who's a crossfit athlete he works out of
crossfit chalk
and his hiv regularly hits 200 on that
so there's no way he's yes it's
impossible that he's going to have
double the hiv of that he'd be beating
like once a minute certain minutes
yeah it's not possible i mean so again
hiv is not really measuring heart
beat per minute at all whatsoever so
it'll correlate but it's not always as
simple as that but yeah you just
you can't compare every system is using
a different calculation i mean a lot of
them are
these days are used using rmssd um but
then a lot of them are also not using
their
rmsd like the apple watch uh doesn't use
that usually they use sdn i believe so
the calculation itself will drive the
number and then a lot of times after the
fact people do math so bio force
ite would take that that raw data and it
would
basically transform it so it was a
little bit more usable so it didn't jump
around
all over the place the way that some of
the other ones would so
you got to be careful everything too
that you the difference is between a
chest strap sensor
versus an optical sensor how it's
measured at a time of day all that sort
of stuff so
i'm personally not a big fan of of whoop
to be honest with you just because
it's measuring at very random intervals
you know if you really want to get
consistent measurements
you need to measure at the same time
each day you need to measure in a
standardized
fashion so we compare where were you
yesterday at this time to where you are
today at this time because if i'm just
walking around or if i'm sleeping
on my stomach versus my side or if i
have caffeine all these numbers
get thrown out the window because
they're just going to reflect that
exact situation but we want to have a
comparison of a baseline state we want
to see where is your body
in a baseline state at rest so some of
them
you know whoop and some other ones will
try to measure you overnight because
they think it's the easiest time to
measure
but the problem with that is they're not
getting a steady stream of data they're
just taking these random snapshots
because unfortunately hrvs it is battery
intensive
it would run your battery into the
ground on any any strap like that if you
had hiv running all night long
it would literally you'd have to charge
it every six hours to keep the thing or
eight hours to keep it actually running
so
instead what they do is they take these
random little snapshots every couple
hours or every six hours whatever they
do other you can't
we can't know exactly how often they
measure it but they take these little
snapshots
and then they compare that but the
reality is those snapshots are
broad i mean you could be sleep on your
stomach versus your back and that'll
change your hiv entirely
will it uh you know you could be oh yeah
absolutely your body position changes
your hiv your
your breathing rate changes your hiv
your mental stretch i mean your high is
it's a sensitive number that's kind of
the challenge with it is
you can change it i mean you could
literally cut it in half by holding your
breath
so basically like different things you
do
are going to change your hiv
significantly so
your body position your breathing rate i
mean i can sit there and mentally think
about something stressful and elevate my
heart rate and that's going to lower my
hiv
you know all these different things are
going to influence it so these little
teeny snapshots
you know are not a very good indicator
of your baseline state they're just kind
of showing us what's happening at the
moment
so most of the research that's out there
that's done
is done with hiv and kind of
standardized measurement period where
it's like usually two to five minutes
every day around the same time because
that's the best way to see what is this
person's
baseline state uh the overnight hiv
research that typically done is done
from like sleep studies
where they do use ecgs and they connect
a bunch of electrodes and they measure
you all night
and they take all this data because
they're in a sleep lab so
there's very little research out there
that shows good accuracy with
kind of random overnight periodic
measurements because again it's really
really
hard to extrapolate what a baseline
state is when you're getting these kind
of random
ad hoc measurements throughout different
periods uh throughout the day or
throughout the evening so
there's like so there's there's lots of
different systems out there and there's
some value to each of them but
personally the way i've always done it
in the way the research supports it is
you know a consistent daily measurement
done at the same time um in general the
same fashion to compare again what does
this person's
normal baseline state look like and how
is that changing a daily in a long term
basis
what's your preferred tool and preferred
time of day
to achieve that yes i mean i had my own
hiv system now i started with bioforce
2011 was when i first came out with one
and i really just saw the need because
it was
really early days there really wasn't
hrv systems out there back then except
for athletes and
you know mega wave and some really
expensive ones and
we measured hrv for uh in a number of
years with with bioforce
and then ultimately i kind of realized
people would would use it and they would
say well why might have you do this
and why might should we do that and at
the time you know all we were measuring
was hrvs i'm like i don't know
like it could have been it could have
been you know what was your diet like
what was your
mental stress like what was your sleep
like what have you been doing for
training
you know hiv does not really tell you
the why it just tells you
what's happening it's up to you as an
individual to figure out why is it doing
this and the reality is it is it varies
a lot as you probably have seen it goes
up it goes down it's all over the map
right
it's not always as obvious what's
causing these variations so
i came out with morpheus a couple years
ago with the idea being let's track all
this other data that's already out there
so we take activity data from any
wearable people have whether it's
you know a fitbit or a garmin band or an
ur ring or
polar and then we do the same thing with
sleep and then we measure heart rate
from training from any bluetooth chest
strap
or any chest strap that people are using
and then we basically measure hiv with
our own device
and then we turn all that data into a
recovery score so
we're taking you know same whoop does
whoop takes the same similar data but
we're using other devices rather than
forcing you to wear
just one so we're trying to be a bit
more flexible in the market because not
everybody wants to wear a band 24 hours
a day
uh not everybody's gonna buy it nobody
wants to pay a subscription all those
sorts of things so
we're trying to use the data that people
are already getting from wearables they
like
garmin fitbit polar apple watch all
those sorts of things
and then we measure hrv using our our
morpheus bands and then we show you the
whole picture of that
so we make it easier for people to again
connect those dots so if you see your
hrvs
doing something it's affecting your
recovery score you can generally see
okay well i i went 15 000
yesterday it's obvious why it's
different versus my average of 8 000 i
doubled my steps
or my sleep spend six hours a night it's
been really shitty so that's probably
what's doing it so you can actually see
all these different pieces connected
because again it's going to be your
activity level it's going to be your
mental stress
it's going to be your training it's
going to be your overall fitness level
your nutrition all these things
are going to drive hrv on a daily basis
and if you don't see the big picture of
that you're just kind of like guessing
what your hiv is doing or you're
guessing why
it's doing that so you like the system i
developed called
morpheus and we're really developing it
for coaches we're working on a coaching
platform to be out here shortly
so that coaches have access to all this
data because that's the one thing i
would say is
you know if you're a coach your results
or your program depend on all these
things that happen
outside your control so if i write a
program this is really what i learned
early on with hrb is i would write a
program and i was like this is great
this is a perfect
program and then it would go to [ __ ] and
i couldn't figure out why
and i'd see all the numbers happening
and make way back in the day this
person's not recovering well
the program's not having the results i
wanted what's going on
and then you talk to the person like oh
yeah i was up i was up till four in the
morning last night playing video games
or we you know i work we're in seattle
or we have a product launch at microsoft
i haven't slept in five days
so you just start to see like my program
results
weren't really all on me they were on
the person once they left the gym to go
do the right thing
so it's it's really it's it's the 23
hours a day outside the gym that drive
the results you get from the one hour
inside the gym and the problem i always
had as a coach was if i couldn't see
that
and they couldn't see that and there was
no accountability and they were screwing
themselves and blaming me for it
it's a bad business model you know like
you're you're
they're coming in and paying me to give
them results but my
program is a small piece of that it's
the potential to have results
but if they don't get enough sleep if
they don't eat the right foods if they
don't
deal with the mental stress
appropriately they're screwed they've
sabotaged all the hard work that they've
done and all the work i put into their
program so you know i realized that as a
coach
i was just shooting the dark without
this data without making decisions
because of this data so i've always seen
there's got to be something out there
that helps coaches
have access to this and help coaches
sort through it because it can be a lot
of data and so that was really where
the genesis and the idea behind morpheus
came from was i wanted to figure out
okay how can we take
all this data because clients are
kidding it right clients have wearables
clients have apple watches they have
fitbits they have uber rings they have
whoops
they have all these different tools
that's collecting this data that coach
could be
using but the coach has no access to it
right it's not exactly like hey
let me look through your apps when you
bring your phone in to me like that's
not going to happen you're not going to
see it so
again we're really excited because after
we've been working this damn thing for
two years
um and we're literally a few weeks or
months at this point in time from having
it
ready to start beta testing and
launching next early quarter one of 2021
so
i'm really excited because as a coach
for so many years you know i i wouldn't
know how to coach anymore without having
to access that data because i'm so used
to being able to see
you know from from my own systems and
just talking to people and dealing with
the systems i've built
you know but even now i still have to
kind of piece things together because i
have to ask them to look yeah i've
looked at more obvious data and
had these conversations but once we have
this tool out there then it's just going
to make it easy for every coach out
there
to to have access to this data and then
we're building in you know messaging
tools and communication to be able to
say hey what's going on your sleepless
go to the [ __ ] bed
it's 5 a.m yeah yeah yeah exactly so
we're billion we're building little
alerts exactly so
basically we'll have it so all the data
is in there and then we've built in this
alert system that'll basically
automatically search through the data
and give you a little notification so
it could say exactly that hey chris
isn't sleeping tell him to tell him to
get his ass to bed
and then you'll be able to send their
message and say hey what the hell if
you're reading this go back to sleep
right so
we're building all these tools in there
just to make this process easy and
seamless and more practical for coaches
to use so something obviously i'm
excited about because we've been working
on it forever
and i think it'll be hugely valuable
just because again all this data is out
there it's just going to waste i mean
people are collecting massive and
massive billions of data points
that nobody's actually using in a
meaningful way they're just kind of
looking at oh that's cool
you know but nothing's actually
happening in the program the coach
doesn't really
know what it is or the coach doesn't
know how to make change their program
and you have just basically a bunch of
data that's being
completely used and i think that's a
huge problem that we can solve that's
awesome man i'm happy for you why should
if people want to go and have a nosey
around where they go
uh just train with morpheus.com so train
with morpheus.com is where we have the
right now we just have the the consumer
app
so if you're you know just wanted to use
our
our hiv system for yourself you could
turn the order or the strap as a coach
we we have we'll have that new system
coming out early next year so once once
we get there we'll have all kinds of
stuff on the website
about it right now it's kind of under
the radar because we've spent so much
time
uh working on it but we actually had a
huge gym we had goals jim
asked us to build this big platform for
them initially and then they declared
basically
administration this year
they went completely bankrupt and sold
the company to a german company actually
so that whole thing kind of went uh went
by the wayside but
by the same point in time they they gave
us a significant investment to start
building this thing out a lot faster we
wouldn't have been able to without that
so we were able to
basically get the whole thing built on
their dime i was going to say
are you saying that you hastened the
bankruptcy
of gold's gym i think we were very very
small part
they repurposed all of their profits
into your app
i wish you were that simple there was
there was quite a few months where they
owed us a very large amount of money so
i don't think we uh
they didn't pay us what they were
exposed to for a long time but we
finally were able to get that once
things
went all the way through but you know
they saw the need they basically want to
build a gym concept where
you had live heart rate training classes
but the heart rate training and all this
stuff was built around the individual
and not just built on
you know some static heart rate screens
up on the wall that weren't
individualized to you so
concept was basically we're going to
have everyone's going to get their
recovery measured through hrv and all
the other things
and then they were going to have a range
of classes from lower intensity recovery
classes up to your high kick your ass
classes and the system would basically
make a recommendation about which
classes were appropriate for you
each day so if you were already smoked
it would say hey you should probably go
to recovery class today
or if you look like you hadn't been
working hard enough and you needed a
good athlete and you would say hey go to
these classes today
so i think we're starting to see this
recognition in the industry that maybe
telling everyone to go in the
gym every day and crush themselves is is
not a long-term sustainable approach
for more most people and it's why
fitness doesn't work you know
unfortunately very well for most people
because they go in they bust their ass
for a few weeks or a couple months
and then they get burnt out or they get
injured or just don't you know
eventually they plateau and they
they get frustrated then they go try
something different and you kind of just
get this merry-go-round of trying
different things but the reality is
it's not the it's not the thing that's
going to make the difference in results
it's
it's how you put all these pieces
together it's it's how much sleep you
can get it's
how much nutrition or what your
nutrition looks like it's can you manage
intensity of daily basis can you manage
emit the the stress in your life can you
put all these things together because
all of those things ultimately
drive results because they all take
energy and there's one thing people
understand is that your body's capacity
to produce
energy is is limited it does not have
this unending pool of energy to deal
with everything
you throw at it so it has to prioritize
and make choices so if i'm extremely
mentally stressed that takes energy if
i'm walking around 20 30 000 steps just
working on a daily basis that takes
energy
if i'm not getting sleep that takes away
from my energy and recovery
first and foremost takes a ton of energy
because if we're going to
break muscle tissue down and break down
all these things as part of the workout
well we have to put energy back into
rebuilding them we have to turn on
anabolic processes and protein synthesis
and we have to put energy into making
ourselves
bigger and stronger and more efficient
and all these sorts of things but
there's a limited amount of energy we
can produce in a day so the body has to
make choices
and the the last place it actually wants
to put energy is into recovery if it has
to just
fight for survival so again people have
this
idea that i'm going to be stressed out
from work and i'm going to take it out
of the gym
and then i'm going to slam a red bull or
some caffeinated drink and get six hours
of sleep and repeat that
and they they try it and that does not
work because again sooner or later
the body's going to take energy away
from recovery and just direct it into
survival mode
and your fitness isn't gonna get better
and eventually you're gonna get a
shoulder injury or you're gonna get a
your hips gonna start bothering you or
you're just not gonna feel like going to
gym for a week and then you're gonna
miss another week and then you're just
gonna start to
kind of fall off and being consistent
with your training it's consistency over
the long term that produces results
it's not how many times you can smash
yourself in the gym in a week
and unfortunately that's what people try
and you know that's why people
often don't don't succeed yeah for sure
so getting into
hiv training what are the ways that we
can help to
increase that number in the gym yeah so
the biggest thing i can mention is
is it's correlated aerobic fitness so
not i don't want to put it out that the
anaerobic and strength and power aren't
important those play roles and they they
facilitate metabolic changes that help
us
in multiple ways and body composition
but ultimately you've got to improve
your aerobic system so
like i said if you look at hiv the
highest people out there the endurance
athletes because they have
the greatest levels of cardiovascular
fitness and they also have the greatest
longevity so there was
a few papers out there but there was a
one study that looked at uh
a meta-analysis and looked at basically
a huge variety of papers a huge variety
of athletes i meant
uh to see how their lifespan compared to
the average and the scary thing was
a lot of athletes especially in the
anaerobic side their lifespan was either
the same or worse
than the average person right that's bad
if i'm going to spend my whole life
training the sport
it should at least help me live a little
bit longer or stave off disease a little
bit
but it doesn't so the only athletes it
consistently found that lived longer
than the average
person were the endurance athletes and
some of them some of
the endurance athletes live an average
of eight years longer than the average
person which is a lot right i mean it's
like 10
longer than the average lifespan so you
basically have to develop the aerobic
system which you know like
could take a uh you know a whole year to
explain you how to do that but the
simplest version
again if you really want to boil it down
to the easiest version is if you spend
80
of your time this is contrary to what
most people think we spend 80 percent of
your time doing lower and moderate
intensities
below i would say about you know below
90 percent of your maximum heart rate
and then you spend 20 of your time in
those higher intensity zones 90
above and you do that consistently five
six days a week you will see your hrb go
up you will consistently see your
aerobic system improve
and it sounds simple but the reality is
it isn't that difficult it's just most
people
again they don't follow that guideline
they spend three days a week trying to
do with the highest intensity for the
shortest duration possible
they neglect those lower and more
moderate intensity zones
and they're not consistent they don't
get enough consistent work in so if you
look at all endurance athlete training
it's not two days a week i mean there's
a difference between
you can get stronger on two days a week
you can do two full body workouts and
most people can gain
gain or maintain strength on that you're
not going to see much fitness
improvement therapy side beyond a
certain point
at two days a week of training it just
isn't going to happen so
you've got to be more consistent with
your aerobic fitness than aerobic
conditioning that's got to be four five
six days a week
consistently but again you want only
about 20 percent of that to be what we
call
real high intensity which i would define
as above 90 of your max
and you want the rest of that to be
below that so you want your combination
of
more moderate longer volume days and
then you want your higher intensity
shorter days but you've got to have
both and unfortunately we've kind of
been fed this spoon fed this idea that
you just need high intensity all the
time like
unfortunately you need more than that
because you can only do high intensity
for so long before you break
and you need something in between and so
those lower and more moderate intensity
sessions allow you to do more volume to
get more stimulus
without breaking yourself so you need
that balance so you know again your
average person that they just spend
you know let's say four or five days a
week up to six for higher levels
and they're consistently doing some form
of aerobic training you know the
majority time they're doing lower more
moderate intensity work
30 40 minutes sometimes more sometimes
less and then they're spending maybe two
days a week doing those higher intensity
intervals
and they are getting their heart rates
up towards maximum and they consistently
do that
you will see your hiv consistently climb
guarantee you
what's the lower bound on that
heart rate like like yeah like 75 80
you know for most average people like
130 beats per minute 120 is probably the
lower
end of where we're going to see the
benefit of that and so like most time
i'll tell people somewhere between like
120
150 160. you're gonna be in that in that
range
for that 70 or 80 of the time and then
that other
20 their high intensity now you're gonna
be up in that 80 90 or 85 90 90
or more of your match heart rate which
is going to depend on
what your max heart rate is but that's
where you're seeing your heart rates in
the you know the 160s 170s 180s that
sort of stuff
so again people think you need to go in
there and do this high intensity every
day
even our fighters even the best fires in
the world i've trained for 20 years at
this point
two days a week of sparring has kind of
been our recipe for success
demetrius johnson the the longest uh the
world record holder in title defenses
now he's bar tuesdays and saturdays
he wasn't in there five days a week
banging it out and being an idiot like
two days a week of high intensity
sparring
and most of the other stuff was
technical drilling and just developing
the skill set and strategizing
you know building strength that kind of
stuff but he wasn't in there five days a
week trying to kill himself that's part
of why he had such a
you know he's had such a long career and
he's avoided massive injuries and he was
able to sustain such a high level for so
long
because again we realized that if you
sit there and beat the hell yourself for
four or five days a week there comes a
price for that you can sustain it when
you're 20 years old for a couple years
but what happens you're 25 when you're
30 even 35
you know and now you're paying the price
so i think the biggest thing is people
just have this misguided notion that the
harder they train the better results
they're going to be but it's more about
the consistency the more consistently
you can train
the better results are going to be so
you've got to ask yourself is your
training
going to be sustainable and if your
answer is well
i beat the hell of myself every week i'm
feeling tired or trying to leave the gym
then probably not sustainable for that
long to be honest with you
one of the things i've definitely been
red pilled on this year
especially from ben greenfield is that
if you are not a professional
athlete you should be training for
longevity in one form or another
like the number of people absolutely
that i know that are so
religious like completely dogmatic
ideological about whatever particular
training methodology is whether that be
crossfit or bjj or mixed martial arts or
bodybuilding or powerlifting or
weightlifting
whatever it might be you think why is it
that you're completely dedicating
yourself to this one particular mode of
training
when it would appear as you've said and
multiple other guests on this show
that so many downstream benefits come
from just
turning over getting your heart rate
into a good place yeah if you can do
that
during let's say that you enjoy cycling
outside and you live somewhere that's
got a great cycle track
fantastic like that's a cool thing to do
but you know
if it means that you've got to just turn
over on an assault bike or on a spin
bike or on a rowing machine or whatever
it might be
you should get into that but people seem
to
sacrifice an awful lot of what would
make them not only be able to do the
sport that they love for longer
but also generally across their entire
lifespan just be
healthier on all markers yeah i mean
look i think we're
as human beings we're we're we have two
problems we're obsessive about things
that
we see a immediate feel good about so we
love bjj we love something we just get
obsessive about a lot of people at least
uh especially in the fitness industry uh
and then number two probably our biggest
downfalls we're incredibly short-sighted
like most people out there are looking
for the next workout next week or the
next
four weeks in the next six weeks i mean
people we don't look beyond
the short term to think like okay what
is what is my what is six months or six
years from now
look like because the reality is those
things are gonna that time's gonna
happen you're gonna get there
but if we focus literally on the next
six days versus six months or six weeks
or six years
we make bad decisions because we're so
focused on right now
we're not we're really not good at least
most people are not good at making
decisions now
they're going to pay off later we like
to make decisions now we think are going
to pay off now
we don't like to make decisions now that
really aren't going to pay off
for down the road six years six months
six sixteen years or whatever the
number may be we're just not long-term
strategic
uh thinkers or action takers we tend to
be very focused on in the moment
and we don't really think about the
long-term consequences of our actions
because we just think god that'll let's
i don't deal with that it's not for
years from now future future crystal
look after it future joel all sorted out
yeah
exactly and unfortunately you know that
by the time that happens
they they've already made their mistakes
i can't tell you how many athletes i've
worked with
from a variety of sports and they're all
you know the once you get to their 30s
maybe late 30s they're like goddamn i
wish i knew in my 20s what i know now
i would still be playing i'm gonna i
can't tell you how many times i've heard
that if i if i knew in my 20s
what i figured out over the course of my
career i would still be playing
the sport i would still be what are
those what are those insights what are
they saying when what do they mean when
they say that
a lot of it they realize the importance
of taking care of themselves right like
you talk to major league baseball
players they're out drinking two three
nights a week after games they're
sitting there chewing tobacco they're
not getting enough sleep they're
stressed out their minds i mean
a lot of them just don't realize the
importance of taking care of themselves
outside the sport
and eventually they start to fall apart
you know they start to lose their their
game and everything
goes to [ __ ] so they start to you know
eventually start looking for ways that's
it's kind of funny because you start to
see the the athletes that really embrace
technology are the ones that are
are older and have been around a while
and they start to realize like if i'm
going to keep
trying to compete with these younger
guys i got to do something because my
game's going to [ __ ] and these guys are
all beating me now so
like i said most of it is they just
start to realize that again you you
can't just go into the
the training with the idea that you've
got to outwork everybody you've got to
go into the train with the idea that
you've got to be smarter than everybody
and that comes with taking care of your
body and not just abusing it so
again you kind of see the younger
athletes they'll just they won't get any
sleep and they'll
they'll have a bunch of caffeine or
stimulants and they'll just be the [ __ ]
of themselves like
especially the mma fighters if you look
at the young enemy fighters they're
sparring four days a week five days a
week six days a week that's like half
what they're doing
and then they they do great for two
three four years maybe five
very most and then they're out of sport
if they even last that long
so you just kind of over time you just
realize
maybe i should have taken a bit
different approach and
you know now it's maybe too late so you
know unfortunately it's just kind of
the nature of the game but there's
enough there's more and more education
out there there's more emphasis on
recovery now ever before there's more
tools right there's there's
all sorts of uh things are coming out
now from from hyper ice and hypervolt to
normantech boots to all these different
modalities are starting to be more
widespread and i think it's because
people are starting to actually
realize how important these things
actually are to sustainable
performance to sustainable health what
are some of your go-to workouts
when you're in the gym and you've got an
hour you've got an alright amount of
time
and you think right i want to do
something that i know is going to
positively affect my hiv over the long
term what are some of the go-to workouts
that you do
yeah so i kind of do a variety of things
i i
i like going outside and riding my bike
so i do get outside and bikes
there's there's benefits of being
outside uh from a high intensity workout
to
play racquetball pre-cove at least i
played racquetball just keep my heart
rate up and have a little more fun than
the sprinting on a treadmill so i tried
to get in the rackball court twice a
week
and then the rest time i just do a
variety of cardiovascular work so i i
tend to do circuits i'm
uh i'm more of a lifter by nature so i
don't like monotony like i hate the
i'm just not the kind of guy who's gonna
do 90 minutes of the same [ __ ] so
i might do five or ten minutes a
versaclimber they might jump rope for
five minutes
they might do some shadow box or
something like that for five minutes so
they might jump back in the burst
climber for another five or ten minutes
so i tend to do like a a you know i call
it a road work circuit
if you will so i'll just use a variety
of movement patterns and a variety of
things
and then like in the summertime i'll get
out ride my bike i'll go swimming i'll
try to be
you know hiking that sort of thing
outdoors so i just like the variety of
it you know some people the exact
opposite they want to do the exact same
thing they want to be
extremely monotonous you tend to find
the endurance athletes fall in that
category are people that are
naturally predisposed to the endurance
side of things they're very monotonous
space so they want to just do the same
[ __ ]
and then you find the power lifters or
the strength athletes are more anaerobic
they tend to hate that sort of thing so
you just kind of fit got to
figure out what people naturally
gravitate towards to and find something
that again they enjoy doing so
if i was forced to be a treadmill for 90
minutes i would kill myself
but other people that's all they want to
do is get on something
monotonous elliptical and they want to
just go for it and they want to just
zone out and that's their
their way of training they enjoy so you
know again like i said pre-covered i was
playing the racquetball about twice a
week and then i would do a variety of
circuits you know another three to four
days a week and generally do about three
days of lifting
i'm kind of mixed in there as well so
usually i just upper body lower body
and total body spread across three
different strength workouts and then
uh a variety of the circuit based
training in between and then then the
a little bit of sport to distract you as
well and you found
yeah exactly over your long career of
training and
being a trainer you found that that's
like an optimal split for you something
that you can sustain and that gives you
the results
for me yeah that's exactly right so i
tended to i again i i'd
fall in the same trap so when i started
playing a bit more racquetball so i get
more competitive i'd start playing try
to play a bit more and start
you know play a little bit longer and
then i'm like god damn it now my
shoulders bothered me like i just kind
of fell into my own trap right
so i could see it coming and i was still
doing it but then i learned from like
okay i
basically kind of realized as i hit 40
about two days a week of high intensity
uh because racquetball has high
intensity it's a lot of sprint work it's
a lot of change of direction
um and it is a lot of load in your body
so i realized okay i can really only
play
high intensity about two days a week if
i'm gonna go in there and play any more
than that it's gonna be just technical
drilling and trying to
get better at the sport and just learn
how to play a sport better but um
yeah it's kind of evolved over time and
then like say the summer time seattle's
you know
a beautiful spot to be so i'll go i'll
ride a bike down a trail to work and
uh not not fast but let's go out and get
my cardio into the bike and
hiking and that kind of stuff so and i'm
going to hawaii here in
a couple weeks so same thing i'll get
some light work on the beach and
you know be outdoors and train and just
uh
i enjoy the the outdoor aspect of it so
i try to do that when i can and then i
enjoy like i said
for my high intensity stuff i like the
sport aspect of it because i just uh
you know i enjoy that side a lot more
there's going to be a lot of
bodybuilders and powerlifters and
weightlifters listening
who don't like the fact that they're
going to have to jump on a yep
a bike and do some cardio now well they
they
won't unfortunately but the the the
unfortunate part about the sport is if
you look around the sport there's been a
lot of them that have
died incredibly young right there's
there's been a number of bodybuilders a
number of power lifters
who are not exactly in the best health
you know and i respect the fact that
look if you want to beat the living [ __ ]
out of yourself to squat a thousand
pounds
be my guest right i mean that's that's
your choice you can certainly do that
but if you if you look at the guys even
like the dave tates and the louis
simmons i mean
i think that you know as they've aged
you can see them taking a different
perspective and dave dave's been vocal
about his
injuries and he's been vocal about
wanting to rehab himself i mean
uh the first the first strength coach i
worked with uh bill gillespie
incredibly strong guy bench press 700
pounds um i believe it 50 plus years old
and he's just i'm
absolute monster um and a lot of these
guys again as they age
you know you see the wear and tear on
them they can't move very well they
can't
they can't get out of bed half the time
they're just in pain a lot of time
and the reality is you know they're
they're probably not going to be longer
than the average person they certainly
might live
a less uh you know shorter than the
average person and definitely an
unfulfilled
life right like it's going to be painful
anyone who's seen the ronnie coleman
documentary like
yeah right very uncomfortable no
but that's it but you know what that's
the
sacrifice that people make to get to the
top top top of the spot
if you've got jay cutler breathing down
your neck you have to go and squat
700 solid ass pounds like for reps and
scream yeah buddy but the vast majority
of athletes aren't getting to that
stage they're maybe competing at a local
or a regional level or perhaps a
national level
but they're not going to do that so it's
a really difficult pill to swallow and a
bunch of my buddies who've competed
at worlds for powerlifting have had to
take this on
they've had to realize look like i need
to concede this is not
my job this is not where my earnings
come from
yes it's where my passion is but just
because i'm passionate about something
doesn't mean that i should give it
everything at the expense
of my life and it's such an
uncomfortable
you know it makes people viscerally feel
and rightly so you care about this sport
you genuinely care about your
performance you want to do well
but you got to let it go you got to make
some sacrifices for you
in 20 years time exactly i think
look i think it's valuable for people to
see the ronnie coleman documentary
because it's it's valuable people see
like [ __ ] i'm i'm going to become like
that but i'm not making that kind of
money
or i'm not having that level of success
i mean what
exactly am i destroying myself for so
yeah i mean look
if people understand the consequences
and they make the decision to do anyway
you know more power to them it's their
life they can do whatever they want and
i think if you ask ronnie coleman he
doesn't regret it
he says the only thing he regrets is not
trying to go for a for five instead of
two with that 800 pound squat
yeah exactly you know what hey that's
ronnie coleman is one of the best to
ever do in the sport you respect that i
mean that's
that's what it takes you know to get to
that level but again if you're going to
put in
all that time and effort then hopefully
it pays off for you and you end up like
ronnie coleman because if you put in
that
time and effort and you pay that price
and ultimately you're just some guy in
this couch at home talking about
his his squat five years ago you know
then you're the al bundy of the world
and you
you you know reminisce about the past
that really was never anywhere near what
these guys were at and the reality is
look
there's only one ronnie coleman there's
only one demetrius johnson i mean
these guys are one in a million or a one
in a billion that get to the very top of
these sports
and i hate to say it but a lot of them
are they're too they come down to
really good genetics and and lots of
drugs and lots of sacrifice
and if you're not willing to have you
know you don't have all that combination
you're probably not gonna get this
top of a lot of these sports so look you
just got to make a decision for yourself
and
people need to have those conversations
with with themselves you know is
is what i'm sacrificing worth what i'm
getting
you know is the juice worth the squeeze
man yeah we uh yeah
exactly we have a concept that we've
come up with over the last few years
called the fitness menopause
and it's precisely what you're
describing there you
for us it was as we approached our 30s
and we realized i'm
getting a little bit out of breath going
up a set of stairs and i've done
bodybuilding like bro lifting for the
last sort of eight years and
i've been overeating protein and under
eating micronutrients and i haven't
looked after my cardio system and i
haven't got any mobility
and you see people that might be brought
on by an injury it might just be brought
on by the monotony boredom
of training and they start to oh i'll
have a look at
yoga i'll have a look at crossfit i'll
have a look at functional fitness or
triathlons or
bjj or whatever it might be and um
that's
what happens man and it you know it
comes across hopefully for most people
not too late
um i want you to ask about the role of
breathing and breath work
in affecting hugely valuable hiv what
can we do what some of the strategies
yeah so i mean like i said that your
respiratory function in your respiratory
capacity is is closely tied to your
parasympathetic
system because it's just kind of how the
two systems are
intertwined so they're like there's
there's a million ways to roam on that
one there's lots of different breathing
strategies out there
but most of them are built around you
know a prolonged exhale
a slowed controlled breathing pattern
and just learning how to mentally
uh disconnect yourself from the stress
around you so you know
go online you can look at mike robertson
and bill hartman they've got courses on
breathing there's there's other people
out there
brian mckenzie a bunch of people have
started digging into breathing there's
wim hof and look
there's lots of different ways and
people are talking about breathing out
there and again
there's lots of there's lots of
different ways to accomplish more or
less the same thing but what it all
comes down to is just
improving your breathing pattern
efficiency improving your ability to
activate that parasympathetic nervous
system through your breathing techniques
uh developing again so breathing is like
a squat or it's like a lunge you have a
breathing pattern that you fall into
based on your physiology and based on
these these training
attributes you get over time so a lot of
it again just kind of comes down to
recognizing am i a very
uh they call it you can basically call
it like a sympathetic or parasympathetic
breather and different strategies around
those things but
you really kind of if you want to dig
into it you can dig into there's lots of
rabbit holes you can go down to but for
most people
literally just kind of spending three to
four minutes a day
focused on full inhales and full slow
exhales where you're getting a complete
exhalation of the
the respiratory system pattern and
spending time mentally relaxing just
doing that is going to break a lot of
the stress cycle that we see on a daily
basis so
this again there's so many different
techniques it's like asking what's the
exercise
you know it depends on what you need it
depends on what you're going to do
so if you want to dig into breathing you
know go find those guys i just mentioned
but
by and large it's again it's just
learning how to take full inhales full
exhalations
and then being able to mentally relax at
the same time if you can spend five
minutes a day doing that
you will i guarantee you'll see your hiv
go up a little bit just because you'll
learn how to
to take a break for a second activate
that parasympathetic system through that
process
yeah brian was on the show a year ago i
had mr mckenzie on and we're now
actually
uh sponsored by his state app
so anyone that wants to get some breath
work and add it into their daily routine
bit.ly
slash state wisdom and you can get two
weeks for free just download it on the
app store on ios
uh those things are huge hugely valuable
i mean literally literally you
if you're if people do nothing else
spend five minutes a day just relaxing
and going through some of those drills
i guarantee you will see your hrb go up
because again it's just we're
we we go through our day and we're kind
of in this chronically stressed out
state dealing with work dealing fly
especially now cobit has
made that even worse and not only that
people are sitting at home doing doing
jack [ __ ] because
you can't go anywhere else right so it's
this bad combination of stress plus lack
of movement is equalling you know we're
going to see repercussions of
of covid long after the virus itself has
gone from this you know
almost a year of uh this change in
behavior that's negative i mean
gyms are shut down uh you're gonna have
to order out and
get food or you know deal with a whole
different nutritional strategy half the
time
and then you're just sitting around
stressed so again we'll see the price of
that but
spending like i said five ten minutes a
day just
learning how to breathe and relax it
just kind of resets the switch and it
can make a huge difference
will will expand out into affecting
an aggregate across the day oh yeah
absolutely i thought
i honestly thought that the dose would
be so low that it would cause a state
change but the uh elongated trait change
would be
like pretty tough to achieve no you
absolutely see it it depends on the
people so the people you'll see the
biggest impact with are the type a
people who just like can't relax they're
just
always on they're always going they have
shitty hrv uh you know they're just go
go go go
like those people just there's something
about learning how to turn that
that relaxed switch on and learning how
to shut that that go
go switch off even if it's for five
minutes they just develop
they develop the quality to learn how to
do it better throughout the rest of the
day or throughout other times
um in the evening so i tend to tell
people if nothing else learn how to do
this because you'll sleep better and
that better sleep will translate to
a million things so you'll see
oftentimes so you take a power lifter
and you say okay i want you to
spend five minutes in the middle of the
day and i want you to do this breathing
exercise and i want you to try to drop
your heart
the easy thing people can do is just go
these breathing drills and look at their
heart rate and your goal is to get your
heart rate as low as possible
i mean just watch it look at just sit
there and get your heart rate as low as
possible because that's an indication
that you're relaxing and then you're
getting that parasympathetic system
turned on so it's a really simple
biofeedback tool as you're doing these
breathing exercises and
trying to relax and you'll find people
suck at it at first because they're
trying too hard to get their heart rate
down
and it's kind of counterproductive but
they'll eventually learn how to do it
they'll learn how to relax and learn how
to see their heart rate come down
and then again that process of learning
how to do that will carry over
into just a better response to stress
and a better
ability to control that that's also
something i would recommend in the gym
so probably one of the easier things you
can do that's gonna be more valuable
than anything else is
as we're doing intervals okay a lot of
times i would say 99 of time what do
people focus on the interval they focus
on
driving their heart rate up and going as
intensely as they can right they never
focus on actually bringing their heart
rate back down
as quickly as they can in between
intervals so whenever i'm coaching
intervals or doing conditioning work
like that
it's not just about the work it's about
the recovery in between the intervals
so i want people to learn how to not
just drive their heart rate up i want
people learn how to drive their heart
rate
back down and so that's again a big part
of what i talked about heart rate
recovery
so i want athletes or people focused on
how quickly can my heart rate come back
down in between interval
and that they can develop that skill
because part of it is just fitness
the aerobic system and then part of it
is the mental processes and the mental
skills
that drive that so you can learn how to
bring your heart rate down faster
by practicing it because again part of
that is an actual skill and it's being
able to
turn that stress system off as quickly
as possible and allow the heart rate to
come back down so if you're in the gym
and you're doing intervals just
literally spend the time after interval
seeing how quickly your heart rate comes
down in 60 seconds or if you're doing a
shorter interval 30 seconds whatever the
case may be
see how quickly you can get your heart
rate to come down and focus on that make
that part of the goal to work out
is to try to drop your heart rate as
fast as you can in between those
intervals
and the better you can get at that the
better you're going to get at just being
able to activate that parasympathetic
system
you know outside the gym as well it's
about a hugely valuable skill i just
call it i call it dynamic energy control
it's
learning how to control that energy
expansion not just by going as hard as
we can but actually recovering
as quickly as you can so it's just a
it's it's another thing to add to your
conditioning or aerobic work that makes
it a bit more interesting than just go
as hard as i can
and then repeat well try to actually
learn how to go as hard as you can
recover as quickly as possible and then
repeat that process and just adding that
layer in
people often find makes it a little more
exciting and it adds a hugely valuable
component to it as well
what is some of the physical traits that
people can do
to achieve that controlled breathing
calm thoughts
yeah all of it so generally speaking if
we're if we're in an extended position
hyperextended position it slows down our
recovery and it slows down that recovery
uh from the respiratory function if we
can get a little bit more of a
flex a little bit more diaphragmatically
advantageous position
and we can work on expanding getting
full expansion of the rib cage and full
breath and then again a complete exhale
while mentally being able to relax and
turn that switch down a bit that's the
combination that will work really well
then positionally
it makes a big difference so if you have
someone that just can't get their heart
rate down they just suck at it
the first thing you have to do is just
sit or even lay down just positionally
your heart will come down a lot faster
if you're laying down or you're seated
versus you're standing so
it's kind of the remedial 101 like you
cannot get your heart rate to come down
have them lay down have them close their
eyes and have them really focus on just
that full relaxation as
late in the laying position okay well
now they've got that down really well
they can get that down
okay now have them do it seated okay now
they can do it seated now have them do
it standing so you kind of go to this
progression
uh of where it's easiest to recover as
lane it's
you know then then seated then standing
then moving
you of go through this progression of
letting them get that but so in in
general
i'll just give you guys some general
guidelines if you're going to 90
more of your max for you know any length
of time
generally speaking use a 60 second
recovery after that you want to be able
to recover between 30 and 40 beats per
minute
from your max so if i'm doing something
let's say my max is 190 if i get in the
180s
i should be able to do a 60 second
recovery and consistently drop at 30
beats per minute now if i do
20 of them obviously that's going to
change and i'm going to have a hard time
towards the end the beginning
but that's kind of our hallmark because
we want to hit 30 beats per minute
in terms of recovery from a max
intensity exercise that's a that's a
kind of a generic prescription but if
you can shoot for that
you know chances are you're in pretty
good condition and you're able to
control it pretty well
most people hit like 10 20 you know at
the most
and they can't do it consistently but we
want consistently be able to drop 30
beats per minute
across at least three to five reps of
high intensity work if you can get there
you can do
that that's a pretty good sign you're on
the right track i'm thinking tomorrow
i've got a cardio session in the gym
tomorrow and i'm thinking
got tons and tons of different ideas
about what i'm going to do i was uh
also reminiscing about spending time on
my morning routine seat there
doing the state app and uh thinking
about some of the places that i've put
myself in
when doing some of those exercises
because it
gets progressively overloaded over time
and
the discomfort that you can come up
against there is really really
challenging it doesn't surprise me that
people don't like doing breath works it
feels like you're drowning whilst not
being underwater
but the the impact afterwards and this
kind of goes back to what you were
saying before
is your training methodology making you
feel like [ __ ] when you leave the gym or
is it making you feel good
the things that make you feel good make
you feel good for a reason a good
night's
sleep a nice healthy meal that doesn't
make you feel inflamed or tired or
grumpy afterwards
a good training session that makes you
feel recovered whatever it might be and
the way that you feel after having done
breath work as well
is just so at peace present
it's yeah i mean those and those that
those characters carry over
i mean again those carry over because
they're breaking that cycle of stress
and they'll translate into better sleep
they'll translate into better recovery
they'll translate into better health
in general because you're feeling good
for a reason because your body is doing
something
that's beneficial and it's an important
thing so i mean that's a look it's a
really simple guideline for for forgive
people if you don't measure anything
whatsoever
you know if you don't if you walk out of
the gym again i kind of like to use 80
20 rules it does apply
if you walk in the gym 80 time and you
feel at least as good as you went in or
better
and then 20 times you feel like [ __ ]
you're probably in the right track
right but if you if you flip that and
eighty percent time you walk in that gym
feeling like [ __ ]
and only 20 times you feel the same or
better you're probably screwed
so you can just kind of use it like if
you if you don't use any technology
ask yourself how you feel as you walk
out of the gym and if more often not you
feel worse
you're probably gonna break sooner or
later because of it who
is the best conditioned athlete
in the ufc at the moment do you think
are there any conditioning monsters in
there
um you know now the dj left i can't i
don't think anyone's
gonna come up to this level but you get
some of the yeah i mean we haven't you
know i hit
we haven't seen a lot of the the five
round wars i think in the ufc that we
used to
see as often for whatever reason i think
people have i think that you saw a lot
of people realize that you can't go
as hard as you possibly can for five
rounds out gassing out and most athletes
can't so they'll
they're people more strategic now about
it i think they're they become smarter
with their energy you do see less
athletes
or fewer athletes gas is not really bad
early rounds because people just realize
eventually that you have to be
a bit more strategic in it so you know i
can't think of anyone off top my head
that i think is anywhere near what dj
was demetrius johnson when he was
still fighting the ufc so i still think
he's in my mind you know set the
standard as far as
best conditions yeah dj absolutely was
best conditioned at the ufc i think
i haven't seen anybody in there that can
that you know i would say has
been able to take that from him even
though he's not in that ufc anymore yeah
it is interesting man especially
watching i was thinking back to
uh tyrone woodley's fight like a couple
of his most recent ones and he was so
strategic with his energy
super super slow you know he looks like
he's walking through mud
sometimes but yeah i'm gonna guess it's
a big dude with a lot of muscle mass
he's probably focusing very very heavily
on conserving that
that energy yeah i mean it's again
that's another skill you have to learn
and it's not just the
the actual skills of throwing punches
and kicks and and
all the things along with it's the skill
is conserving energy and knowing when to
use
what you've got because if you use it at
the wrong time or use it for too long
you're going to pay the price i mean
look khabib is always well conditioned
because he's just a mentally tough
bastard and i think he's also extremely
you know i think it's both i think he
was the the guy who was also
he he was very well conditioned and he
was like dj he was extremely mentally
tough so you were never going to see him
fall apart because he had both the
fitness and the mental side of things
locked down that's why you could just
take people and pound the [ __ ] out of
them for five rounds or usually they
didn't last that long
just an angry angry little russian
associated man isn't he yeah absolutely
but he was like he was i loved watching
him fight he was he was fun to watch
because he's beat people mentally and
physically he's
he's kind of like a throwback to the the
older wrestling crowd i mean so it's so
funny because the ufc has
gone through this weird evolution where
early on the ufc was specialists
you know it was the guys that were
really really really good at one thing
that ultimately won and first it was the
bjj guys from the hoist gracie era
and then it became the wrestlers who
basically just took everyone down and
then it was strikers again
and then there was this point where
people became had to become really
well-rounded
and then now you kind of like if
everyone's well-rounded then it's back
to like someone who's well-rounded and
has a specialty
so that's interesting yeah yeah i mean
it it's it's kind of the way it's
evolved so that everyone everyone now
has to
be well-rounded enough they don't have a
big hole in their game because you will
get exploited if you suck at wrestling
if you suck at striking if you suck at
grappling
somebody will beat you because of that
so you have to at least have
pretty baseline competency uh you know
against all those things but then
you still now have to have something
that you also need to be a freak in
something as well you'd see me a freak i
mean yeah khabib was a freaking
wrestling right he could take you down
and beat the hell of you
uh again i think i hate to go back to dj
games i think dj is the most
well-rounded my perspective because he
was good at striking good at wrestling
uh good at grappling and really he was
he was pretty equally amazing at all
three of those and he was extremely well
conditioned and mentally tough so i
think that's why he was you know able to
have the dominant run the ufc i mean i
was in his corner for the very
first title uh he won against benavidez
whatever year that was 2008 or nine or
whatever whatever how that was and
uh you know to watch him consistently
performing the level he did was
just a testament to the the athlete he
was but yeah it's funny to see that game
kind of come almost full circle in a
weird way but everyone's
everyone's skill sets raised but you
know it's kind of come back to this like
hey
you can't suck at anything you've got to
get everything but then if you have one
thing that you're just amazing at you're
going to be able to use that because
you know that's your your advantage so
it's it's it's been a crazy uh thing to
watch the sport evolve for the last 20
20 years or so now i mean i started
watching it uh you know i started
training guys in 2003 so 17 years of
watching
the ufcs and prides and dreams and 1fc
and the whole the whole thing in between
so it's
it's been been a fun ride i bet it has
uh what about the world of weight
cutting
is it still as brutal as we used to hear
about a few years ago whereas the
recent rules and warnings yeah i think
i think i think the rules yeah i think
it's probably it's been down a bit i
mean i think people are
part of it is you know sooner or later
you realize cutting a massive amount of
weight maybe isn't the advantage you
thought it once was
it's it's not uh i mean when you had car
mcgregor dropping down to 145 i mean
jesus that guy had a huge
advantage there but aside from those
situations you know a lot of guys just
are realizing that you're so drawn out
and you're so depleted that you don't
always perform very well because of that
and then you also had
one sc and matt hume i've worked with
for a number of years one of these kind
of changes
their entire structure like they have
hydration tests and their weight classes
are actually a step above where
they normally are so the one 135 is
actually fought at 145 and they've
kind of re-engineered the whole process
of of cutting weight and what weight
classes are and i think
um you know that that's been successful
for them they've had very few
issues over there so if you don't if you
don't actually make hydration you can
lose
your purse it's it's a totally different
thing than making weight so you actually
get hydration checks
and you have to stay within certain
certain guidelines of that or you
can be fined for it so [ __ ] i think we
yeah
it's it's changed things in the the yfc
world entirely
and i think the ufc eventually you know
kind of started to realize it's not good
to have athletes missing wait not good
to have athletes going to the hospital
before because they can't fight so and i
think the athletes themselves have kind
of realized that
maybe actually just being really uh you
know well conditioned and coming in in
shape
and not having to drop 20 pounds is a
better recipe for success in trying to
have this
you know five or eight pound weight
advantage over your opponent when you
actually step in the octagon so
i think it's gotten better i mean the
the old days were crazy and i can tell
you
and the stories of walking into you know
we'd be in the hotels together you'd
walk into a sauna the hotel had one the
gym had one and you just see these guys
just
murdering themselves five days out i'm
like man you're five days out and you're
trying to drop weight in the sauna
you're screwed
like you could just see this prolonged
draw and you could see the the torture
they had ahead of them so
we always focused on you you want to
drop as much as necessary but you want
to drop it over the shortest time
possible
like literally you you're better off
dropping as much weight for
you know the last day than you are
dropping a moderate amount away for five
days because that prolonged depletion
that just crushes you
and so again guys should make this
mistake of going into
fight week you know let's say 15 pounds
of other fight weight and they try to
drop that 15 pounds over five days or
more 20 pounds or whatever it is
over over the last four or five days of
the camp before the fight
and again that's just a stupid thing to
do because you're you're chronically
depleted for
five days and you just traveled probably
across the world or across the country
at least in a different time zone
you're eating different foods you're
stressed out of your mind because of the
fight
like you're throwing all of this [ __ ]
yourself and then you're trying to drop
all this weight on top of it it's just a
terrible terrible
recipe so we wouldn't try to drop really
any weight until the last 24 hours you'd
want to be in position
from a from a camp standpoint toward the
last 24 hours and then the last
you know really it's two four or five
hours you would drop as much as you
needed to but you wouldn't spend the
entire fight week trying to drop weight
for god's sakes
so that's you know it's the mistake
people made but they hope
some of them learned from it some of
them didn't i've never had to do it
thankfully but
i've watched a bunch of different
documentaries there's this famous clip
that keeps on getting reshared on ufc
of from one of the ultimate fighter
seasons where this guy's so
so far over and he's trying to escape
and his two coaches have got their foot
on the edge of the sauna
he's like trying to open the door like
no no no no it's five more minutes five
more minutes oh yeah and then he's got
his sweatsuit on and
he's like just crawls out onto the floor
and they peel this sweatsuit off him
there was a bbc documentary about a
liverpool mma fighter watching him in
his hotel room
hot bath covered in towels uh putting
ice in his mouth and then spitting it
back out like
every trick in the book and he just
looked it was
just so much suffering and you think
right okay and now you need to get
yourself from that place
into a position where everything is
firing
you've got absolutely everything figured
out and you can step into the ring with
someone who's trying to take your head
off
yeah i mean it's crazy like say you want
you want to go basically weigh-ins would
be you know the the
friday morning and then you're fighting
sometimes saturday afternoon i mean
sometimes you have less than 24 hours
you know like you said to go from the
doorsteps of death to
trying to fight for your life and you
know in a day so
it's it's stupid honestly like i said
that the thing is
you have to you're not gonna have that
big of a weight advantage like
let's say you cut five pounds or eight
pounds or whatever more than an extra
guy like those five or eight pounds
are rarely the difference in the fight
it's it's it's about so much more than
this this moderate weight advantage you
think you can get over your opponent by
cutting more weight than he did
like it's you know it's it's rarely
going to be the difference maker
compared to
the difference makers the conditioning
is the you know what your state is and
you actually can get in the octagon so i
think people were
uh kind of stupid honestly for for
taking that approach for so long and
thinking that you know
this this one weight class difference or
this five pound weight advantage or
whatever was
the deciding factor in the fight of the
career when there's so many other things
that
that go into that uh that process that
are ultimately driving success far more
than that so
i mean i'm not i'm not betting man but
if i was
i watched all these guys over here i
could pretty much tell you who was gonna
lose the fight and who wasn't half time
because you'd see him in the sauna
practically dead on tuesday
you know he's kind of kind of figured it
out who was probably not gonna win their
fight
you'd see it you know at the hotels uh
before the fight
yeah i don't know man given the choice
between being
five percent heavier in the ring or
twenty percent more positive and ten
percent mentally sharper
that i'll i'll take the
having a little bit less mass but
feeling great
and firing on all the cylinders
yep it was just this mistaken thought
that bigger was always going to be
heavier was always an advantage and
really
it's not always the case i mean
there's fights that were won and lost
because of it but there are more fights
lost because of lack of conditioning
poor weight cutting and all the other
things that come along with that
mentality so i just think it was
you know it's again this this
unfortunate idea that
pain and suffering somehow leads to
success so we kind of have built in
somehow
that people thought like oh if i can
draw more weight than the other guy i
can i can have an advantage or i'm going
to beat him because i'm going to be
five pounds heavier when fight day but
it's just not that not that simple
especially as people's games have
evolved i mean it's the skill side the
conditioning side and the mental side
are driving this
not the five pounds that you might have
on your opponent or the six pounds or
whatever
it's a uh a common thread that i know
i've heard you talk about it a lot
to do with our belief that more is
always going to be better that bidding
ourselves in the gym is going to lead to
more results
and we're seeing that as well as you say
this extremist mentality
humans are absolutists and it's the same
as well when you find your new
racquetball bjj whatever the next
physical obsession
you just go all in and finding that yeah
well jessie middle is
precisely where it works right yeah well
so there's
there's an experiment done uh i don't
know decades ago with these
these rats and they repeated some other
animals but they basically would take
these electrodes and they would kind of
tap into the dopamine
uh centers in the brain and they could
press a press a little lever a little
button and that button would basically
send a direct
current into dopamine response centers
and you get this dopamine spike
and they could self-control this right
so they could press this button this
little lever and it would just
constantly send the spike into the
dopamine centers and and cause this
elevation
and what they basically found is that
these little bastards would lever press
to their own detriment to the point they
would stop taking care of they'd stop
eating
they would stop taking care of their
young they would basically stop doing
everything like they would just sit
there and lever press and lever press
and lever press and lever press and
lever press
until they would fall apart and die more
or less so
basically if you look at what we're
doing i mean that's kind of these these
sports and these
extreme things they they kind of give us
that little doping spike of like oh [ __ ]
it's novelty it's it's
it's this this whole thing driven around
how our doping system rewards things
and so we're just seeing this this
constant mentally stimulating dopamine
spike reward from
from these different things but again
we're doing it to our own detriment
and we're doing it to our own uh
long-term you know
sacrifice and and we're gonna pay the
price but again these these mice and
these other they
did monkeys they actually did human
beings for god's sakes and this study
would never be
approved today uh but basically they
would find that if you if you tap
directly into that dopamine center
and you gave somebody a button you could
press to get there they would do
nothing else like said they would stop
nursing their young they would stop
uh eating they would stop doing anything
they would just sit there and lever
press themselves
into oblivion to get that dopamine spike
and i think in a lot of ways that's
what we do uh as human beings we we get
we get so focused on whatever it is that
causes that little doping hit you know
whether it's a high intensity workout or
it's
uh getting the gym and and sparring or
doing something or it's you know
racquetball in some
stupid sense i mean we just kind of get
these little these little hits
and we just keep pressing that damn
lever until sooner or later we
we break and something pays the price
for it but it's just kind of it's
interesting how we're
we're wired to seek reward like that's
gambling it's if you think about
gambling so why do we why do we gamble
because the uncertainty of gambling and
the potential to win
makes us again put in those dollars and
pull that lever
even though people are smart enough to
realize you're going to lose
i mean have you been because you've been
to vegas right people
have spent billions of dollars playing
games they know they're going to lose
and it's the same reason
it's how our dopamine system was wired
to
seek reward and to seek these things and
to
continue to do things at the immediate
idea of reward rather than the long-term
idea of reward so
you know it's just kind of a byproduct
of biology and the only thing we can
really do is be aware of it and try to
protect ourselves against it and try to
shift our thinking a bit towards
longer term uh goals and decision-making
but it's it's hard it just kind of goes
against
human nature and you know we're we're
meant to we're meant to be here for
a certain amount of time and die so it's
we're not really meant to be here and
definitely meant to be here for
you know certain number of years before
we're all gone and we just kind of live
in the moment half the time and
pass our genes on the next generation
and the whole process repeats
totally right man i had a guy called
andrew steele who's written a book about
longevity and the cure for aging
um getting older in an ageless society
and this
longevity whether it be through
transhumanism
whether it's enhanced through drugs
whether it's uploading our brains into
computers it's like a
fascinating ethical discussion to think
about what a life would be like where
there is
it's infinite it's it's got no no end to
it and
until that happens people need to stop
[ __ ] the [ __ ] up by doing stupid
workouts
look joel man i've loved today it's been
really really cool it's everything that
i wanted to get out
about hiv if people want to find out
more or
follow you online why should they go
yeah so eight weeks out dot com
inside just the number eight and weeks
out dot com you can jump on the old
instagram
uh just coach joel jameson o
j-a-m-i-e-s-o-n
and uh post on post everything in ig and
facebook you can find me on there but uh
eight weeks out it's the main site and
and other than that ig is probably the
two best places to find me
perfect thank you man awesome good
talking to you
[Music]